[Music]
thank you
I have been out scoping the areas and uh
set some game cams out we got a little
bit of a bear on the camera this time of
the year definitely is a good time to
get a bear if you're gonna eat it we're
gonna see how it turns out hopefully
that bugger's still in the area
Brianna is the one who is going to be
pulling the trigger
see ya
she's definitely capable of it I'm not
really worried about it as long as we
see one I'm pretty sure she's gonna be
able to put a hole in it and put it down
[Music]
oh I'm making my own rounds just kind of
you know uh not buying it from the
factory you know saves you money and you
know you barely get a little bit better
bullet a little bit more accurate bullet
there we go
yeah yeah
bullet made ready to go bang black bears
are definitely something to respect they
can definitely end you if they want to
I think I might have jerked a little bit
at that one
yeah just relax and take another shot I
saw you pull that one yeah I'm
definitely an experienced Hunter I've
been doing it since I was really little
my dad would take us up on mountains
we'd go down through muskegs and always
get deer so I definitely feel the
pressure that we need to go get a bear
go come on go
come on
you've got this I figure I can do it
I think you're hitting it man bullseye
this one will shoot a bear
all right let's try to get the hell out
of here all right
it's a Bear Hunt yeah hope it's a good
one oh yeah
there ain't no other place I could ever
live you know other than here
[Music]
that's so beautiful but yet brutal at
the same time and reminds me how lucky I
really am
[Music]
get all them
chips so
oh yeah I can see it now this one's a
really dull one right here I can see
it's been rocked oh yeah oh have you
tried and I'll go to this one right here
like this
[Music]
from the moment
I've heard that Curly wasn't amazing
amazing it's exciting being able to
actually hear about someone that's this
good and now getting taught by him he
was drugs go all the way through don't
worry about being slow or anything it'll
all come with time Chase has a very very
dangerous piece of equipment it has no
mercy on anything with me probably
having more chainsaw experience than
anybody around here I mean it kind of
makes sense for me if the teacher and
teach her right
it's been amazing finding a new friend
out here
well we'll check your homework and see
if you pass
oh damn
God you better
be careful there they'll put you on full
time
very good for your first time I'm
excited for this yeah well next thing to
do is load all this stuff up in the back
of the truck head out and go see if we
can find some standing dead trees yeah
are you ready for this no but we'll find
out
[Music]
I've got
two different types of cabbage
and I do believe
I have a couple of little brussels
sprouts here these are brussels sprouts
they look identical see cabbage brussels
sprouts can't tell the difference
that's why I have the label still in
them
with their seeds
these are going to be going in the in
the ground here pretty soon
I can get enough soil to plant them at
and the dirt I'm going to be using is
dirt that I've freshly made it's similar
to this dirt right here
but it's never been adjusted
and it needs it needs to have its pH
adjusted morning morning morning morning
morning morning
I was just talking to my babies here
they're going to get new homes pretty
soon they'll be happy yeah I think that
the tide is climbing now so we should
probably get get cooking absolutely we
need to get the heck out of here
Matt's my oldest son and he's back in
country now for the summer so we're
gonna take a little Joy right down the
coast to a little rock pile it's about
15 miles south of here on a nice day it
kind of reminds me of an eight hole in
the South Pacific
this is my absolute favorite time of
year because everything is growing now
and it's not too warm
perfect working weather absolutely
it's real important to me to be able to
Source my garden vegetables locally
however most vegetables don't grow here
naturally so you have to harvest this
bounty of shells that happens to exist
down there
put that in my garden and recreate the
environment that they need to be
productive
that looks like a good spot right there
dude extremely approachable
[Music]
I can't see my feet
yeah I feel kind of funny walking
through this much yeah Indian celery you
can just see how Lush this growth is
it's gonna be good for your vegetables I
can tell you that much well I'm thrilled
have you ever seen what they look like
under a microscope sandy beaches no I
have not
that's amazing
looks like the cosmos
these things seem thicker than the
standard butter clam shells that I'm
used to digging so I'll bet you these
are just really old
back from
prehistoric times
I you know I never did the paleontology
thing
well I had a little epiphany
one night when I was laying in bed just
thinking about you know the upcoming
gardening season and a little bell went
off in my brain and ding ding hey you
don't have to buy lime anymore you can
just gather up enough buckets of crushed
Barnacles blue mussel shells a wide
variety of clam shells remove all the
moisture put that in my garden and raise
the ph so in the future I'll have you
know probably a lifetime supply
all right let's head home
[Music]
there's something about this place
that's unexplainable
I want to sound like a weirdo or a
hippie or something and say it's magical
but there's just something
hey I wasn't going to start this early
but we got a caught a bait jumping in
here
something's chasing it so we're gonna
give it a shot
okay I am gonna troll
for cohos which are silver salmon
I got a plan to build a cold smokers so
what I want to do is is catch enough
fish to fill that smoker and uh
hopefully I can get this done before it
starts raining
what actually just started I should have
never said that
before it stops raining
oh yeah they're jumping right in front
of the boat I'm gonna go right through
them get into the Kill Zone up here
[Music]
okay I have no idea how deep I am
oh yeah
this feels like salmon Maybe
definitely bigger
oh it's a rockfish you gotta be kidding
me
the Rockfish definitely like my
presentation
but I need the salmon to come after it
do me right good give me a salmon I want
to fight a real fish
oh that's a salmon that is a salmon
oh I think I missed him
oh he's there he's there he's there oh
there he is there he is there he is
don't go under the boat I'm not losing
I'll lose him
oh he's pissed
we have salmon on the boat
that hurt
cool
cool that got the blood moving again
let's get right back at that
it was raining and wet and some wind
here and there pretty soggy but I stayed
and I made it pay oh man that's fun
I don't know I got another one already
I barely got to sit down
oh don't you dare go away man
you're going in the boat bro
they are down there thick today
yay more meat
right on
my fishing trip went from dead to Red
Hot
I found the squat
[Music]
we're in them
what I have found living out here you
know you just gotta learn to not be
discouraged and just stick with it
because it's trial and error and one day
you're going to be successful
I gotta get these fish cleaned and
brined
and ready for the new Smokehouse
I got plenty of fish now
foreign
I'll eat a whole pack of them oh yeah
[Music]
all right we're me and Brianna
definitely have a years of experience uh
hunting deer it's kind of how we feed
ourselves and get our meat but when he
comes to the black bear we definitely
don't have any experience with that
feel it it's not warming anymore but
it's fresh it hasn't turned black yet
it's a huge good sign all righty the
work starts here
I want to be able to hang the whole
fillets of fish in there like you see
the natives do it that been doing it for
years and they fillet them down to the
tail like this
that way they just hang in the smoker
like that
I gotta get these fish smoking
[Music]
[Applause]
well here she is
this is my retort vessel for going
inside the incinerator
you put your
product in here whether it's wood this
case is going to be ocean seashells
and I'm going to bake them hot enough I
might have to fire it a couple of times
to get them to turn into powder
and add it to my garden to sweeten the
garden
help bring the ph up in the soil
time I get this old girl into the shop
I built basically a homemade device here
a while back so I could cook myself up
some charcoal
I'm going to take that technique
and I'm going to superheat
a big batch of shells
but the last time I fired up the retort
furnace the base got really warped out
of shape so I'm gonna have to cut that
off put some legs on that Bingo all have
a new furnace
there we go sometimes you just need to
have a bigger hammer
property of
Oil Company Kansas City Ammo
this thing came from Kansas City
all the way to Alaska God knows how long
I was floating around before I found it
and now it lives on
when I look at trash I see valuable
things
and I think when the bulk of society
looks at trash they don't see the value
that I see
every time I repurpose a piece of junk
it it makes me think of my dad because
my folks were products of the Great
Depression so even from a real early age
you didn't throw anything away that you
could repurpose this is just all by
guessing by golly I just want to make
sure it'll
stand up
I'm in the process of doing the same
thing that the old-timers did
and I think we should all teach the the
younger generation you know how to keep
a weather eye out for just about
anything you can repurpose
this is going inside the incinerator
you want to make sure
[Applause]
look at that fit right in there that
fits in there just the way I wanted it
to I guess it's time for me to
start a burn here
this is the spot
this is that
there's a couple yellow Cedars right
here is that one of the ones you were
thinking about cutting yeah yep perfect
sounds good to me I'm gonna watch you do
it
learn a thing or two okay
cool things almost bigger than me yes it
is
thank you yep firewood is the
never-ending story we're always going to
need firewood year round freaking nasty
out there I know there ain't like a cow
pissing on a plant Rock I am looking
forward to being able to go out and cut
down a tree myself to be able to get
firewood when Carl's gone this lifestyle
does not afford us to be able to wait to
do things
this one looks like it'll go right where
we want it
looks a lot bigger from right here yeah
my dad grinds and sharpened many
chainsaws I do know the potential for
danger of running these things it's not
a toy
curly is going to walk me through what I
need to know and correct the mistakes
that need to be corrected
curly is one of those ones that has been
doing it so long he knows what he's
doing
[Applause]
oh yay
this is our undercut
yeah
the start over
so it's got to be that way to pull the
tree where we want it to go yep
yep absolutely okay
I guess we're ready to let this tree fly
here we go
[Music]
I've caught several newbies I really
don't do it too often I mean it's uh
while I feel responsible if that person
didn't ever get hurt
[Music]
logging is a very dangerous occupation
it's like one of the most deadliest in
the world in that
you gotta respect that fact otherwise
you ain't gonna come home one night if
you don't
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
damn curly done deal it went where we
wanted it
yeah you did that amazing that went
exactly where you said it was going to
go
oh that's my favorite smell in the world
don't get any better than that yeah I
know this is amazing
there's one down yeah the next one's
yours too okay I am down with that
[Music]
yeah
good Lord
a little hard work you get her done
this is my chest freezer
and
it's not energy efficient so I want to
convert it into a cold smoker
because having a freezer that runs all
the time zaps my battery bank and
basically all I need is a box that holds
smoke so I think this is all usable and
it's going to be easy to clean with that
surface on there let's get busy rocks
if this works out it'll be huge for me
because this will add to my ways that I
can preserve fish
it's kind of what you do out here you
use what you got and figure it out
beautiful
now
what I need to do is
have my fire here and then run a pipe
into here so that way when the smoke
goes in there it's cold
that is what I'm shooting for here
my plan is to cut a hole in here
and a hole in here so that marries this
burner now how I'm going to cut through
that metal is going to be another uh
thing I have to figure out but there's a
wheel there's a way Roxy
[Music]
there's lots of ways that you can
preserve your meat out here
the difference between a cold and a hot
smoker is my hot smokers I have the
heating unit right inside the smoker so
it Cooks the fish
this I'm going to put my heat Source
outside the smoker then it's just the
cold smoke coming in and flavoring my
fish well I was going places there for a
minute
good enough for government work huh
who gives it what it looks like as long
as it works
I like it and it doesn't even look
half-assed well I think all I need now
is some Alder and I'm going to fire this
thing up and see how she works I love it
when a plan comes together
your heart's definitely pumping when
you're kind of walking up on this spot
where you don't know if at any turn you
might see a big bear sitting there and
so the adrenaline was definitely pumping
Bear Tracks
the Bear Tracks are big buddy
with this bear hunt I guess I'm just
trying to prove to myself that I can go
out there and do something I've never
done before and be successful at it even
if I'm a little bit scared
it's weird
I don't know what that's all about looks
like a dead eagle or something
is crying
there is so much time back there it's
definitely a berry area it gives me hope
yeah
we'll get something maybe
oh my left eye has got something with me
holy man you see a bear right there I
see his back right over there over the
edge yeah
get the guns go grab your gun don't see
a bear we see a bear let's go
let's go
we got him there we see a bear we see a
bear we'll wait forever if we finally
see there's no idea that we're here we
gotta be really quiet make sure that
we're just sneaking it up on him we're
on the other side of this island he has
no idea that we're here he's just
lumbering around
happy as a bear
and so we're gonna try to sneak up and
get a shot on I'm gonna stop over at
those islands on the way and uh See How
Far That range is
[Music]
well we've been scoping out the whole
Bay from this little rocket out here and
uh we finally saw a nice ice Barrel
there on the beach right where we were
streaming lately and so we're gonna try
to sneak up on them and see hopefully we
can get a shot hopefully some struck he
shows himself to us
[Music]
yeah that's duffel torch off really
quickly
get some Heat going
I've got the retort furnace rebuilt we
got the shells I'd say now it's time to
torture off and I'll have all the
calcium and lime and whatever I need to
tune my garden up now for the cannon
when you fire this furnace off
you want as much wood packed in there as
you can possibly fit
it's imperative that you get it up to a
certain temperature and keep it that way
for several hours a little air on the
bottom
little areas on the top and all the
loose ones in the middle
[Music]
foreign
there we go add a little Go Juice
well let's see if we can get ignition
it's got to get up to a certain
temperature than that waste it'll get
hot and it'll start burning the gas
it'll get real flammable real quick
Houston I think we have achieved liftoff
not my friends
is how to bake some clam shells
what's up
bro you went right here
why we're going to the woods after where
I know just be alert
foreign
and then hit once it fires off again hit
the trigger real fast okay
take your chain break off
Chain break
I'm I'm gonna call it I'm not gonna put
this right now it's starting to
frustrate me really bad
side of the beach
Maybe
so apprecially came all the way back
here for nothing well I don't know
obviously not this way or he's gone
right
damn it one got away man
close
just lends itself well to the salmon
because it's a very mild wood it just is
great flavor for the fish because you
could still taste the fish it doesn't
overpower it
got my wood now I can fire up smoker
frustrated you know you just Adrenaline
Rush wears the person out and you are
doing great you're doing a very good job
Morgan I mean no thank you I appreciate
it it's I mean you're really weird for
me you pay attention I like that kind of
scary sometimes even though this is the
easiest part right here
take a break and come back to it
it'll be all good you know
[Music]
I had a couple of minutes uh I'm just
waiting for that thing to burn down and
well I could have I could curl up take a
nap but Sun's shining try calling myself
into singing singing the blues
[Music]
the only way I could you know be the
most accurate description of what I am
or who I am in this community is I kind
of know a little bit about everything
I hear a lot of people refer to me as
the mad scientist
[Music]
there isn't hardly anything I haven't
tried doing out here you know you name
it I've done it I don't have an ego you
know the size of a Volkswagen minibus or
anything like that I just know what I
know
unfortunately that makes me a
know-it-all so
I'm the village know it all
fire looks like it's burning down a
little bit and I'm gonna let it go out
cool off tomorrow morning me I'll come
out and see if I got some some product
but I'm actually kind of comfortable
right here maybe I'll just sit and watch
it a little bit longer
[Music]
all right are you ready for this no but
we'll find out
well there's your tree
your tree is ready to be cut
do you want to walk me through these
real quick
lift up on your trigger oh yeah that's
right
should always down
okay
now let her rip
you're gonna have to hot come clear
around right where my finger is so how
am I doing that I've never done a try to
keeping this straight as level as you
can
you're gonna aim it right for that bull
fine just go ahead and start that
Adrenaline Rush that you get when you're
running a chainsaw there's nothing like
it and she's shaking like a dog broom
pits but it'll get better it's just part
of learning you know
now come here go ahead and put it up
like I showed yeah
just like that go for it
[Music]
this is my first treat
Curly's letting me do it and learn
so it's kind of scary
[Music]
you did it
so now you're you're ready for your back
cut yeah okay I'm going yep
[Music]
hey hey
okay
please put your saw out
pull it out
[Music]
damn
holy there you go congratulations thank
you
I got the shakes though
I think your limp was quivering
well it's vibrating me and I'm just
sweating and it's just honestly this
thing is still heavy for me yeah it is
you can just cut a nice smooth cut off
the butt of that always
leave that stuff out in the woods
I'm still very nervous using the
chainsaw
but the more I do it and the more I get
out there the better I am able to run it
and the more comfortable I feel
beautiful
[Music]
look how nice and you're throwing some
big ass chips too
I'm sweating
that I mean a little tree but I can't
even keep this
Ah that's funny for a first time it's a
beautiful stump
the the beauty of it is is it went
exactly where you wanted
[Music]
well let's see what we got
cooling overnight
oh look at that
see how tough that stuff is yeah see
that's what you're looking for right
there you can just crunch that in your
hands this will turn into small pieces
and powder
the consistency of these shells is just
perfect I can grab onto them and crush
them and that tells me that there's
going to be lots of fine powder that'll
be quick release this is exactly what I
was shooting for
things don't get lighter you should get
older it'll get heavier
but right now
I'm gonna be screening my lime
from these shells
so I get all the fine stuff
and that's what I'll use immediately
[Music]
and my goal was kind of having a
lifetime supply of this stuff and I
think I'd probably achieved that goal
[Music]
basically anytime you add crushed shells
to your soil it raises the ph and allows
your plants to accumulate the the
correct amount of nutrients yeah I can
just tumble the way it caramels it's
it's the stuff
if it's too acidic it can't do it if
it's too alkaline it can't do it so you
wanna
a balance in between well I'd almost
call that enough if more than enough to
probably do my whole damn Garden
it's pretty common place it's a I think
some well-documented science behind that
I think that's going to be good for now
I'm gonna take what I need now
get a couple buckets of this pack it
over to the greenhouse mix it up and
we'll go from there
Sammy's secret recipe
[Music]
I am excited to see how this thing works
and I got me some
edible fire starter
throw some corn chips in here
and get this done the trick is is don't
eat them all
I think there's probably a lot of people
don't know it but when you're camping
and can't start your fire corn chips
potato chips anything with a lot of oil
start your fire instantly it's like fire
starter
[Music]
these are my
Alder biscuit set I cut earlier
this is where my flavor is gonna come
from
now that I got this smoking pretty good
I meant just see
what's going on with my
smoked pit
[Music]
oh yeah
that's what I'm talking about I think
it's time to put that salmon in there
now
the smoker's filling with smoke I could
fit a whole lot more fish in there and
salmon smoked in this Alder is
unbelievably good it is just delicious
I'm very pleased
not bad for a bunch of junk I needed to
throw away
it's gonna work
[Music]
and scope out pretty much three cricks
yeah so it's a good spot yeah yeah
let's find a spot to post up
[Applause]
with this bear hunting it seems there's
a lot of just sitting and waiting and
letting them decide when they're going
to come out for you he's got to be
present and clear-headed in that moment
all right the Bears broke you in the
sand over there
[Music]
bear bear bear
I think that might be the one you want
to take Brian it's got a nice Brown face
that's the very one
foreign
[Music]
Brianna took a shot at him we're not
sure if she's hit him or not
um
I thought that Brian has missed before
but
several times I've been proven wrong I
don't know what's going on exactly I got
to get up here and see
tore off the creek here
damn it damn it damn it
ah
Oliver's out there on a mission to like
keep looking to see if I wounded it
because I have made shots where we think
we it got away but really it's just
laying back there but I really don't
think that's the case I don't see any
blood anywhere yeah now I just want to
kind of lick my wounds I'm kind of just
bummed out about it and never like when
I make a bad shot so
I don't know what I'm looking for dude
a little bit of Hope
now I've shot it up over here so we're
probably not going to see another better
I'm really hard on myself when I miss an
animal just because that's one thing I
feel very confident
I pride myself in my shooting abilities
so it definitely hurts my ego a little
bit
it just makes me realize that like I'm
not perfect and I have to just keep
trying it's our first bear hunt
well since we didn't get this beer today
just means we got to go home and regroup
and uh decided whether we're gonna try
again for Bear we're gonna have to find
another food source for the fishing
season
I'm definitely more concerned about
Brown I really want to just go give her
a big hug and tell her it's okay and
that she's still a badass to me
sometimes you win some sometimes you
lose some
time to go home
it's okay
to find success here you just gotta work
smart and find easier ways to do
everything
and I keep getting better and better at
it
well now rocks we get to find out how
our smoker
really worked
um
[Music]
yeah
we did good Roxy
that rocks sorry you can't have it
I think by me passing on my knowledge to
the younger generation and that you know
that's gonna help Port protection
survive down the line she's not gonna
have any problem getting her firewood I
don't think I cut down my first three
yes he did you did a good job
it's a good first experience yes yes
[Music]
this is the
Gary malburger method I've
about
crapped myself one time I went over
there and
by God if he didn't have
some of the nicest cabbage I'd ever seen
boy it's sure nice if he could come over
here and see me doing this I could just
see him nod and wink you know that's how
you do it
it'd be proud of me
[Music]
hell I'm proud of me
oh
[Music]
I'm not a better Hunter not yet not yet
okay I've made shots like that before so
that's what's like frustrating it upsets
you because it's just like I've made
shots like that so
I'm sorry man
come here Brianna's not done hunting
bear until she gets a bear the bear
should have just let her shoot it
because really she's got a grudge
against him now they're all in trouble
they all need to watch out I'm really
stubborn so definitely determined to
keep trying
the second you lose is when you stop
trying
[Music]